les prépare comme s'il allait à la
guerre ils sont ni médecin ni infirmiers
mais de simples bénévoles en formation
qui ont répondu à l'appel de leur église
pour aller d un système de santé
catastrophe
c'est comme un film d'horreur dit peter
simpson qu
il enfile cinq soirs semaine une
combinaison pour se jeter dans la gueule
du loup les zones rouges des hôpitaux
qu'ovide de toute la région de moscou
aussi
ces bénévoles offrent du soutien ce qui
peine respirer on ne sait jamais qui
sera le prochain
c'est terrifiant parce que c'est
l'inconnu d'elisabetta une des dix
nouvelles recrues qui écoutent les
consignes attentivement mais avec la
peur dans les yeux y avoir quoi comme
brice je les prépare aussi
psychologiquement 10 infirmières était
mené bahia et je leur demande surtout de
faire preuve d'empathie peu importe la
situation car 100 % des cas critiques
sont des patients non vaccinés qui
aurait pu s'en sortir dit le docteur
denison
il ya consacré sa pause pour nous
expliquer à quel point le variant et
dangereux avant il fallait une semaine
pour que leur santé se détériore
maintenant c'est en deux ou trois jours
qu'ils sont placées sous respirateur
reste qu'à moscou les patients ont de la
chance dans leur malheur les autres taux
crocodiles d'eau dans certaines régions
c'est dans les corridors que les malades
dépérissent les médecins qui nous avons
parlé et qui n'ont pas le droit de le
dire à la caméra nous confirment qu'il
manque cruellement d'oxygène et qu'il
faut laisser les gens mouraient
l'oxygène cette précieuse denrée les
hôpitaux vont désormais la chercher là
où ils peuvent même celle qui sert de
carburant aux fusées russes est mise à
contribution
nous avons décidé de suspendre les tests
de tir de moteurs de fusée a confirmé le
directeur de l'agencé spatiale
comment un pays qui a développé le tout
premier vaccin au monde a pu en arriver
là le directeur du fonds
d'investissement qui commercialise le
vaccin n'a pas voulu répondre à notre
question lors d'une conférence de presse
virtuel où il a vanté l'efficacité d'un
nouveau vaccin le spoutnik lightbox
piqûre de rappel
mais ici vacciner ou pas la vie continue
souvent comme si de rien n'était
le taux de vaccination demeure
obstinément bas à peine 29 %
comme tant d'autres natalia refusent de
se faire vacciner ou de porter un masque
c'est de l'égoïsme et de la désinvolture
dit peter
mais j'essaie de garder mon sens de
l'humour
et à ces gens là je le redis on se
reverra dans la zone rouge et comme
avant chaque session de formation les
bénévoles se recueillent pour que le bon
dieu les protège
mais les prières ne suffisent plus pour
surmonter cette quatrième vague ici
tamara alter escaut radio-canada moscou